ladies and gentlemen this year's sexiest
man alive is interest
[Applause]
round of applause okay so he may not be
the next Bond man but Aegis Elba has
been named the sexiest man alive and we
are here for it I know I'm not surprised
by this choice I'm sorry country fans
but Blake Shelton came very left-field
last year yeah and you know what people
is finally just acknowledging what we
always need to be true they called him
sweet and smoldering on the cover and
that is exactly what he is yup he is hey
guys I'm Courtney tezo and I'm Hallie
Stevens so the British actor is now the
33rd man to hold the title but II just
told people mad quote it was a nice
surprise and ego boost for sure I mean I
don't know why he surprised but that
would stroke any person's ego to be
called the sexiest person in the world
we want to know if you guys feel like
this year's choice was the best or who
would you have chosen let us know in the
comments nobody else it was meant to be
him he is a salt-and-pepper snack YUM
he's a full-course meal I'm very
fortunate that when I do trainer to get
muscled quick okay so after being voted
sexiest man alive
a Juris interrupted his own moment to
encourage people to get out and vote in
the midterm election which we're here
for yeah I mean as if he weren't sexy
enough now he's using his platform for
good oh he loved a good man and guys if
you've been on Twitter he has his own
Twitter emoji and people are using that
Twitter emoji like crazy today
this year the Internet is in full
agreement with people's choice one
person wrote fine at people this sort of
makes up for last year's utter [ __ ]
yep bleep that out another person said
this incredibly accurate choice almost
makes up for the time y'all said Blake
Shelton was the sexiest man alive
well another person said I see y'all got
it right this time this is all very
subjective I know there are a ton of
people out there who think that Blake
Shelton is the sexiest man and like us
we feel like interest was but what makes
a jurist so amazing I think is the
platform that he uses for himself he's
so smart he's so charming that in my
opinion is sexy yeah and not too
as an accent he is like a bad hot
kickboxer I mean he is so sexy I can't
even stand it
okay she's having a mom I'm really gonna
move on because we have a treat for you
guys here are the top five sexiest
moments from past the present so his
first notable role was HBO's the wire
now this is a series where him and
Michael B Jordan were on screen so maybe
that's a hit to next year's sexiest man
alive I don't know I'm putting it out
there I could see it I like Michael B
Jordan but who could forget this
shirtless shower scene and no good deed
Oh hotness overload I can't but my
favorite thing is I love a goofy man my
boyfriend knows that dancing around and
being silly is so hot to me and interest
is on fire with this and if that weren't
cute enough then there's this super
super sexy shirtless workout pic whoa
yeah and we all love any guy that can
rock a good suit I mean in that suit and
tie Justin Timberlake said it well you
know being near certain times we love it
so obviously we're all swooning but one
person who is probably not swooning over
this news idris his sixteen-year-old
daughter i would be cringing a little if
my father were called sexy let's just be
real i think i'd be proud but i'd
probably also be super embarrassed yeah
but one thing that his daughter is good
with is keeping him grounded so i mean
any sexy man needs that kind of person
in his corner right yep even if it's his
daughter all right and another lucky
lady in the world right now is his
fiance Sabrina she shared the news
writing that's my hubby hashtag
chocolate for the win hashtag love
waking up to his face of course you know
people are gonna speculate that that's
you know that they're already married
but we know that hubby and wifey those
things are used loosely so we are green
with envy but we want to know your
thoughts do you think that interest was
the best choice for this year's title
who is your top pick and what is your
vote for his sexiest moment yeah we
definitely want to know but we also want
to see your favorite internet reactions
to aegis the sexiest man alive
announcement don't forget to tag us we
won't see those you want to see those
funny ones guys so let's keep the
conversation going
until next time we've got
you covered for your pop culture fix